my mother started the business in 1983
27 years is my whole lifetime in the
store this is my mom's legacy and her
history and all her hard work and all
her tears and all her hard labor and now
I may not be able to make it and we may
have to let it go my name is Lucy angle
I am the co-owner of Lupita's corner
market and we were located in Los
Angeles California when my mom opened up
the business this was a Lupita's market
in the Peethas market because of her
name she was a old school entrepreneur
and being a woman in a time where there
wasn't a lot of women only small
businesses is not easy she was fighting
her way through and I would just
remember my mom going to multiple places
waking up at 5:00 in the morning to save
10 15 20 cents per item just knowing
that she did all that she still took the
time to try to do small things for us to
make us happy this is where my brother
and I grew up and this corner market
means the world to me and I know that it
means a lot to a lot of people as well
this market has always been a place
where kids call home sometimes you know
community families loser their family
members and we would fundraise for them
here and my mom really has always been
that kind of person and you know you
just gotta give back you know whatever
little we have that you can give to
someone who has let's just do it to keep
a small business and a little market
going you know it's it's really
difficult and most markets are actually
have to close you work holidays you work
all the rough days I didn't I didn't
grow up with you know the Thanksgiving
dinners or big Christmas dinners we
usually worked on those days or my mom
had to work so we weren't able to see
her on those days you know her body had
basically you know broken down from all
the hard work that she's done and other
health issues that she had and the last
few years I remember in high school my
mom has had always respiratory issues
and asthma
we spend about two to three holidays in
the hospitals because you know she was
sick of the market slowly started kind
of deteriorating in a sense we really
started having that conversation about
hot selling the business it was very
difficult to see my mom have to leave
you know you have a strong connection
with your with her business where please
where you grew up with the community and
it really um was really sad that we were
gonna have to leave at some point it was
a conversation that was a hard
conversation that we had and you know
obviously we're always gonna take care
of my mom make sure that she was okay
and unfortunately when you have Erin
entrepreneur and you don't have you know
at 401k you're not going to have a
retirement plan you're you know it's
very hard when you're living day by day
the business started coming into that
place where you're just fighting for the
last ten cents of the dollar every
single day so it was a reality we had it
face I just think that in my life you
know I can't see there now my mother
taught me how to persevere my mother
taught me how to fight my mother taught
me how to continue no matter how hard
things got I knew that I wasn't going to
go out without a fight and I knew that I
had to continue to figure out ways to
bring in more income and and and try to
sustain this business and to do it for
my mom and do it for our community do it
for a family one of my many passions is
to help others and I knew that keeping
this business I would be able to do it
this is my mom's legacy and her history
and all her hard work and all her tears
and all her hard labor and now her kids
get to be the second-generation owner
and sustain and maintain the same kind
of values that we have she taught us
if your specifically this community it's
very hard to get quality food every
single person who wants to eat healthy
but doesn't make enough money cannot eat
healthy a corner market has a lot of
influence when it comes to the community
you have the ability to feed people you
have the ability to control the way you
sell and what you sell I had this idea
like what if I bring in more fruits and
vegetables what if I do some smoothies
and I make some sandwiches
you know with our prep license and see
what we can do and I saw that people
were really reacting to it and they
really liked it my mom retired and we
actually had a blessing happen to us and
we were one day just here and the LA
Food Policy Council come walks into our
doors it completely changed her life
[Music]
because of that we were able to get
funny we were able to you know speak to
people that wanted to help us and help
the community I took in and said yes to
every single thing that was offered to
me no matter how much work I had to put
into it and no matter how much time I
had to do it it completely changed
everything and ended up were picked for
in a complete transformation through the
organization and we found partners and
we did some funding through that and
that's how we were able to create would
be this quarter market and and it is how
it is today at the end of the day the
reason that we're here it's not only to
keep my mother's legacy alive and to
keep the business going but there can be
constant businesses that can come in and
walk in we can leave Sunday but nobody
is going to have that history like we do
27 years the connection with the
community and it makes me really happy
that I am growing this business and then
I get to help my family I get to
continue my mother's legacy and I get to
make an impact and whoever thinks that
you know you can't do it you can because
you can start out of nothing and my
direction was always with food and food
brought me here at the moment you know
I'm still work two jobs I work at a
night job and I worked my business
during the day but when you're actually
passionate about what you like and
you're actually passionate about what
you love you are willing to work those
48 50 60 hours a week to pay your bills
and to actually follow your dreams
I am newest at angle I am the co-owner
of Lupita's Corner Market and I am
following my food dreams oh yes
[Music]
you